lenir first of all congratulations a
very important Victory to maintain your
chances at the national championship
going into the last to as you were
getting ready for this game uh during
the rest day were you thinking that this
is a must-win situation for
you well yeah thank you uh no I mean I I
was thinking that uh it's uh I just have
to play well I mean I wasn't thinking
that I need to win this game uh that I
was forced to win this game or anything
like that I was just taking the more
simple approach um just try to play my
best chess and um yeah if chances uh
come to me then I'll I'll try to take
them uh and that's uh that's what
happened in the game I got quite a nice
position uh from the opening I was very
happy because uh it was risk-free
advantage and and quite hard for black
to defend I think I didn't play precise
did his opening Choice surprise you
because you are known as one of of the
best theoretical players on the planet
he tried to shy away from all sorts of
known Theory and you were spending some
time in the opening as well were you
surprised by
that yeah definitely I was surprised I
mean he always goes E4 E5 so I prepare
for that and uh yeah the filor I mean
it's a it's a surprise but also I mean
not not not a very unpleasant one
because white gets a white gets a nice
position most of the
time yeah I was thinking but but yeah I
was trying to remember something but
then I think what I played is sorry it's
quite decent and white should be
slightly better and and and then yeah I
was able to to keep increasing the
pressure absolutely and tell us when did
you feel like finally you're breaking
through at this point the structure
changed you were getting this attack
going on on the king side was this the
area where you felt like finally your
attack is showing
off yeah after B5 on this dc6 queen C6 I
felt that I had a huge Advantage because
even I can play B4 after Queen takes A6
just to deny the C5 Square um um from
his Knight and the Knight can't go to B6
either because my pawns are restricting
the Knight quite well but I thought that
I can even uh yeah maybe this was better
um and then Knight G4 eventually should
be uh big Advantage but I thought that I
can allow him to play B4 and and it's
good anyway but I um I thought that
after Knight H2 B4 uh I can go uh I mean
Knight H2 Bishop B7 Knight G4 B4 I
thought I can go Knight D5 and yeah like
in the game yes uh but then I but then
takes on D5 Bishop takes Queen C7 I
didn't find I mean initially I thought
that here some Knight H6 or something
will will work for me but uh but I
didn't uh I wasn't able to make it work
maybe it doesn't uh so I went for a more
positional approach and uh it was anyway
I think quite a quite a nice Advantage
it was a very difficult uh position for
him he was also getting very much down
on time I want you to take a look at
those last final uh seconds and tell us
your perspective let's play
it at this point were you sted to look
at the clock were you aware of the fact
that he's down to two seconds I wasn't
aware at all I was surprised when I
looked at the clock and I saw 30 minutes
on his clock I thought yeah maybe we
made the time control but then yeah I
saw but I wasn't aware when when he was
about to make the move I I was trying to
to calculate some lines I mean how to
play after Queen C4 it's what I was
trying to do and then I realized that he
just lost on time but the final position
is probably lost anyway because um yeah
after Queen C2 I can simply play
probably Rook F1 or something and and
and it's just lost yep that's that's
correct Rook to F1 defend the F2 Pawn
there's no promotion the F7 Pawn is in
Shambo uh this one is a very important
victory for you ler
congratulations and good luck in the
last couple of rounds thank you our
congratulations to you as well and